i mean this is a project that was a long
time in the coming uh um tell me about
did you ever sort of wonder if it would
actually happen or did you yeah stay
calm um you know i always doubt
everything but uh i i'm i'm very uh
tenacious and stick with projects and
work them and work and then work them
and when you get talented people like
the people on my left it makes it a lot
easier and once made a decision to tell
the story from tonto's perspective all
kinds of
new doors opened up and
um
you know it was always going to be about
that relationship and uh
suddenly with with you know you're
telling the story of tanto telling a
story things like the landscape become a
character in a movie and
um
trains become like a violation of that
landscape and so you have a sort of
native american perspective even in the
scenes that he's not in but when gork
called and said this is the movie and
johnny's going to play
tonto you sort of knew that all bets
were off and it
you were going to reference westerns but
you were going to have to do something
new
and then we talked a lot about um
what would be the best ingredient to rub
up against johnny's tonto
and we started riffing on you know jimmy
stewart
liberty valentine's liberty balance and
i remember saying to gore what about
jimmy stewart he's again jimmy stewart
on acid you know would be we were
writing johnny and a young jimmy stewart
basically you know and then army came in
and read and he was so
kind of out of time and and and and sort
of buoyantly optimistic and he has this
kind of
um so he was great he was a great energy
on set too day 120 when
nothing's working and everybody's just
dirt in your sandwich and you just
you're a mess and he's like look what we
get to do you know he has such a kind of
you know there's trains and there's
horses and he was so like energetic it
was
you know it kind of reminds you of you
know what a privilege it is to to do
this for a living i think johnny is such
an original artist he's not going to
want to come out of the same box twice
and it could never be jack in the wild
west he's one of the best physical
mimics i've ever encountered he can
see something once and just capture it
perfectly his coordination is just
amazing this character is constructed in
some ways that
to his you know natural gifts as a
silent actor
i mean it's amazing to be on the set and
watch him because he's such a relaxed
lovely man
and you realize how incredibly in
control of his instrument he is when you
watch the movie
and the collaboration between he and
gore
you know it's a there's a familiar box
but it's also um
you you i think if you end up writing
thinking too much about his previous
incarnations you're hamstrung you have
to write about the character and i think
this is a departure from some of his
other inventions in the sense that
there's a very dark backstory that
informs him and informs some of the
madness and absurdity
and the first thing gore showed me was
gave me this picture that johnny had
constructed of the bird and the makeup
and it was you know what does the bird
mean and what does the makeup mean and
that was part of the the journey because
it you know it didn't it couldn't be
flip in this context the historical
context of this story not just
coming at it from tonto's perspective
but even the lone ranger i think in from
what i know of the of the um
of the original series he he lives by
his code and his code is well
established and we wanted
something more dimensional i mean
somebody who's struggling with that code
i mean has these noble ideas he arrives
in the west with these concepts of
justice and and how do you reconcile
that when it can be purchased you know
when justice can be bought and sold so i
think
you know at least we tried to
to see him struggle with those ideas
i think his role is the most difficult
in the film because
he's the straight man on some level
and
we were talking about it the other night
and it
he's such a lovely presence on the set i
mean really is fearless and and um
but the quality i didn't really
articulate to myself until this the
other night when i was watching the
movie again is that he's without vanity
he never tries to wink at the camera to
say
i'm i'm cooler than this i mean he he
he completely inhabits that guy and i
think the turn he makes from from the
kind of guy
you know sniffing the wind behind tonto
saying are you getting anything from
that horse to the guy who beats butch is
a seamless
transition i think something very
difficult
um
and and again so i mean i think he i
think he had the most difficult role and
i think he kind of pulled it off
brilliantly i never thought and it would
be anything more difficult than
photographing on boats but
trains are an absolute nightmare um
they at least the boat you can turn it
you know when the sun is changing you
just grab some anchors and you just keep
rotating the boat and you can you know
the train is stuck there and
it was kind of um
yeah it was our shark and jaws i guess a
generation has lost the the fun of the
western because it just hasn't been
around for popular culture
and i grew up with them i grew up with
them on television i grew up with them
in the movies
you know sergio leone and and uh
really
clooney's with more of his later work
and john ford and howard hawks and some
of the great directors did fantastic
westerns and we had bonanza and you know
uh have gun will travel we had all these
great shows on television and
kids just aren't there they
we just didn't have them around so
i was desperate to to bring it back and
the first picture i ever produced in the
early 70s was a picture called the
culprit cattle company i think i'm the
only person who saw it but
uh it was uh it was a kind of a wagon
train with a young kid on it a movie and
it was a lot of fun but
but uh anyway i i hope that this picture
does what
westerns need and get a large audience a
lot of kids to appreciate this genre and
attract more filmmakers to making them